you've bought two of the strongest
parents in the Disney verse mouth so
that makes you like a pretty big deal
it's just too bad that your dad jump
ship when you were just a baby he could
have taught you so much about your godly
powers sure your mom was no piece of
cake but at least she stuck around right
the mistress of evil and the god of the
underworld don't come off as a
lovey-dovey couple but believe us when
we say that it was love at first sight
it is a Maleficent maybe divorced but
once upon a time they saw something
special in each other keep watching to
find out the truth about Hades and
Maleficent love story but it adds up it
doesn't end on a high note no no I left
your mother the big reveal if there's
one thing most of you kids have in
common it's having a missing parent
since the first descendants film came
out in 2015
fans have been curious to find out who
mal Edie and Carlos his dads are and who
Jays mom is too but it wouldn't be until
the third descendants film that the cat
got out of the bag despite keeping it a
secret from everyone but Evie now
finally spilled the beans and revealed
that her father was none other than
Hades the god of the underworld Ben was
shocked to say the least and more than a
little terrified am I invited to the
wedding after all Hades would eventually
become his father-in-law
Hades did what he had to do fans were
certain that Hades would turn out to be
mouths dad and they were right in
descendants three mal and Celia walk
into Hades lair to steal his ember but
he catches them in the act
now calls him dad before they join in on
the wicked duet do what you gotta do but
before they can belt out their emotions
a tease reveals that he was once married
to Melissa sent easiest person to get
along with Hades then tries to bond with
mal over the fact that they both hate
Maleficent but heat is a pretty strong
word so mal denies it saying that she
doesn't hate her mom because at least
she stuck around
but what we're curious about is what
Maleficent did to merit Hades hatred at
all he once loved her enough to marry
her but then again both Hades and
Maleficent don't have the best track
record the big bad Maleficent Maleficent
is said to be the incarnation of pure
evil
she takes the small things to heart like
being left out on a guest list
Maleficent is the antagonist of the 1959
Disney movie Sleeping Beauty and she's
known for sentencing King Stefan and
Queen Leah's baby girl Aurora to die on
the eve of her 16th birthday
luckily for Aurora Merryweather alters
the curse condemning their kingdom to a
lifetime of sleep if the princess should
ever prick her finger on the spindle of
a spinning wheel Maleficent has done
some awful things but cursing a baby is
by far her evilest deed and it's
something she has in common with Hades
the big bad Hades just like Maleficent
story Hades story also begins with a
christening his nephews to be exact
convinced that he should be the one to
rule over Mount Olympus instead of his
brother Zeus Hades plans to overthrow
him problem is there's a prophecy about
sousou-san Hercules showed Hercules ever
grow to be 18 years old he'll be strong
enough to beat Hades and the Titans so
what does Hades do he scents pain and
panic to turn Hercules into a mortal and
end his life to prevent the prophecy
from coming true both Hades and
Maleficent committed terrible crimes
against helpless children proving that
they were a match made in the underworld
maleficents love story Maleficent hasn't
had the easiest run when it comes to
love which is probably why Hades found
it hard to be married to her long before
Hades and Maleficent tied the knot
Captain Hook tried to get Maleficent on
board but she zapped him with her staff
until his hook was all that he had left
but in 2014 film Maleficent we find out
that the mistress of evil was once in
love with King Stefan who she had met in
the forests of the Moors unfortunately
for her the King returned her love by
cutting off her wings sparking the
rivalry that led to princess Aurora's
curse so far the time Hades came along
he had his work cut out for him Hades
loved history before we tell you exactly
how Maleficent in Hades fell in love
let's find out about Hades romantic past
long before hati start up the villain
and Hercules story he lived on in Greek
mythology as this story goes a tease who
hated living in the cold and lonely
underworld kidnapped and married
Persephone he forced her to live with
him for a full six months before
striking a deal with her and letting her
rejoin her family for the rest of the
year despite being kidnapped Persephone
eventually came to love Hades but by the
time Hercules hits the big screen in
1997 Persephone was nowhere to be found
so as it turns out a tease has had not
one but two divorces and he dated
someone on the Isle of the Lost
after Maleficent - but more on that
later love at first bite both Hades and
Maleficent have appeared in a handful of
Walt Disney Productions so they met long
before the Isle of the Lost was created
in season 1 of Disney Villains the
series Maleficent is sent to retrieve
one aterna Boggs precious items from
Hades well if it's an OB is her master
and goes to the underworld to find the
stolen artifact babies immediately blast
Maleficent with all his might and is
super impressed when he sees that she's
still standing a tease a Maleficent have
a love-at-first-sight moment Halloween
with Hades in another Walt Disney series
called house of mouse Maleficent and
hades come face to face once again but
this time Hades is the only one swooning
after getting rejected by Maleficent a
handful of times
Eadie's goes to Mickey Mouse for some
help so Mickey teaches Hades how to be a
nice guy and even dresses him up in a
Mickey outfit but when Hades tries to
woo Maleficent in his new outfit she
turns him down
telling him how much she hates nice guys
Hades goes full on Hades when he gets
shut down and even threatens to turn
Mickey into a roasted Mouse
that's when Maleficent finally sees
Hades evil side and sparks fly these two
definitely had a history before winding
up on the Isle of the Lost
so why did their relationship take such
a sour turn the new
in October of 2019 Maleficent mistress
of evil hit the big screen and fans were
quick to point out that Conell the
leader of the dark Frey is the
Maleficent movies version of Hades sure
he and Hades don't look alike or act
alike but they both have a common goal
to free Maleficent of the people she
serves Hades helped Maleficent escape
from Turner bog and Disney Villains this
series so there could be a link there
fans would have loved to see Hades and
Maleficent featured in the same
live-action Disney film but that has yet
to happen now that we know who Hades and
Maleficent were before appearing in The
Descendants franchise let's take it way
back to when mal was born the villains
and a baby now story begins 20 years
after beasts and fairy godmother revived
and trapped the villains on the Isle of
the laws but at this time mal is only 16
years old so that means that Hades and
Maleficent were dating or married for a
full four years before mal was born we
know that Hades walked out when Mao was
just a baby
so something big had to have happened
for Hades to throw in the towel it is a
Maleficent we're definitely in love and
yet before she could start walking and
talking
Mal's parents got a divorce and Hades
wound up hating Maleficent with a
passion so what happened let's look at
some theories no justice no revenge
Maleficent Hades and the rest of the
villains were used to being free and
powerful and being locked up on the Isle
meant that they were trapped and
powerless
we all saw how enraged Hades was over
beasts decision he was literally going
crazy there was no justice or revenge to
be had instead the villains were trapped
like animals and treated as such
chances are Maleficent's need for a
revenge became all she could talk about
and
as Hades wasn't coming up with any
master plans it's possible that she lost
respect for him and started treating him
poorly Hades goes berserk there's no use
denying it
Hades lost his marbles after a few years
of living on the Isle before getting
locked up on the Isle all Hades had to
do was snap his fingers to get what he
wanted but after the Isle
eighty's had to do everything with his
own two hands and the same goes for
Maleficent taking care of a newborn baby
as an average human being does isn't an
easy task for an all-powerful villain
chances are Maleficent in Hades had more
than a few spots leading Hades to walk
out on his wife and daughter powerless
there are so many reasons why Hades
would hate Maleficent with a passion but
we don't exactly know what went down
between them but what we do know however
is that Maleficent finds powerful and
evil men attractive and seeing as Hades
went from being the god of the
underworld to a powerless stay-at-home
dad it sort of makes sense that
Maleficent would stop loving him after
getting herself a daughter she might
very well have been the one to break
things off with Hades this would totally
explain why Hades hates Maleficent after
all he obviously has a soft spot for mal
who he watched for wept from afar Hades
instead of moping around and trying to
win Maleficent back Hades moved on to
someone new and guess what in return to
the Isle of the Lost a descendents novel
he ended up having another kid by an
unknown mother who he named Hades he is
part of the younger villains in the anti
heroes clue so it seems to assume that
he was born much after mal one of the
reasons why Hades and Maleficent never
got back together could have everything
to do with little Hades existence after
all
Maleficent isn't one to forgive easily
by the end of descendants three now
gained both a father and a half-brother
despite him not making an appearance in
the film one big happy family
the question on everyone's lips is will
mouths parents ever get back together
well chances are if Maleficent in Hades
attends mal
royal wedding they might be reminded of
their own and fall in love all over
again
but first mal would have to find and
turn that poor lizard back into the
mighty Maleficent again and who knows
how that'll go would you like to see
Maleficent in Hades in a live-action
Disney movie sound off in the comments
and that's a wrap subscribe to our
Channel and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching the thing we'll catch you next
time
[Music]